[Music]
hi hello
hello who are you two and how do you
know each other i'm dominique
and i'm erin i'm dylan and i'm renee
this is my wife she says she's a
boyfriend girlfriend
how long have you guys been together
this is the interracial edition
it might be i know there's some uh
black female empowerment channels that
are going to love this
yeah the black men don't stand with you
so go get yourself another race
because you deserve better black queen
oh man it feels like forever
we've been married for five years
tomorrow do you look at each other's
phones all the time i don't like going
to hers and be like ooh who are you
messaging but we both know each other's
passwords so
[Music]
weird so yeah she can't hear you but i
can hear you this is so
trippy oh my god the back the background
dylan no did i not
oh [ __ ] what's the background it's her
i just looked at it with the titties out
hey i ain't mad at you bro bam bam
bigelow
if she got good ones and you're proud of
it
put them on your phone yeah but i better
do get a little reminder i'm not mad at
that you know i mean
me on my phone i got nothing play a
violin track
[Applause]
i don't think i could though i don't
think no no no i got a logo
because i couldn't imagine being in
public and then pulling my phone and be
like yo whose titties is that i'm like
my girls my girls that's just not like
man that's dope
i just looked and then i was like
titties
okay what do you want to look at first
gallery
oh i know there's a picture of my butt
in there there's a picture of us naked
in there please don't look at that
he says there's a beautiful photo of you
two naked that he hopes you click on
no i didn't say that he's just [ __ ] i
don't remember him ever taking that
oh wait oh there no no no
no no no i clicked it there is a picture
yeah there's a picture of us
naked let's see pics
um tick tocks oh no i'm trying to cover
it but it's a screen recording
you guys you're gonna get freaking my
body how do you feel that he has so many
nude photos of you on his phone
it makes me feel like at least someone
in this world desires this body
yes i will take dudes every day and
there's people like that
i'm mad at that no do you but i just
want to take a second to appreciate it
especially it's your wife he's adult
he's got screen recordings
someone's tick tocks
that means she sent it as like a
temporary thing and he went nah
this ain't temporary this is permanent
this is for me forever
hey i'm not mad let's go through let's
see if there's
anything interesting on google oh he
searched up only fans so maybe he goes
on only fans
he searched up [ __ ] fuq
it's porn oh it's that a porn site
that is i found where you go to okay god
damn it
any texts you can look at oh yes yes
okay let's see
messages he spelled my name wrong
and this is march 11th and you still
don't know how to spell my name
that's rough
wow dude they've only been dating for
like
two to six months i don't give a [ __ ]
what what's her name though
i i don't give a [ __ ] well it's her name
i don't i don't give a [ __ ] yeah
i can tell you don't care because what
your wife probably got a simple last
name
doesn't matter of course it matters no
it doesn't you want to know why it
matters no way to matter why matters
because here's a weird thing about names
if you're really familiar with someone
you don't say their name that often
no you may not even see their name that
often that's correct
so if the name's complicated i will make
sure i know how to write it
if i love the girl but that's me that's
just me that's me no matter how freaking
complicated it is
i'll know the [ __ ] out of the name
that's just to me disrespect to me
i agree i agree with saying it
writing it saying it writing it right
but to me
i could i could forgive that but that's
me hey man yeah yeah but then again you
haven't been on the daily market so you
can't no
doesn't matter you can't no you can't no
you're telling me you're going to do
something
that you've never had to do doesn't it i
know i'm wondering what i'm saying but i
know i'm not
the people i'm talking with i'm i'm not
even friends with them
if i interact with them i'm going to
make sure that i know their name and i'm
not even in a relationship with them
because i do i do business with them or
whatever i'm amazing because
that's something that is important to
them [ __ ] been [ __ ] up my
name
numerous times okay in my life oh okay
okay
right to your childhood yeah we got it
damn
i wanted to understand cause this is
like yeah because me yeah absolutely
and that's why i said i'm super good
where did he touch you
show me show me right here on the heart
between those titties no but you know
what the thing is that actually makes
sense yeah
but and that's why i said that's why i
said numerous time i said that to me
yeah tell me yeah it's important yeah
yeah it's like whenever someone
because because because how your name
spells nobody would guess it yeah
and just just when someone it's not even
my girlfriend
if someone's writing me a message it
pisses me off
when people said hey abba and preach and
write that [ __ ] with two b's
it's three letters two of them are the
same
and you add one the [ __ ] is wrong with
you
and the top of the sheet is that the
name is written
on the title of the [ __ ] you open up
messages written abba and preach
i be written card correctly and then you
[ __ ] that [ __ ] up
it's not even my name and it gets to me
[ __ ] obligated
it's even worse when it's not
complicated a b a
you add a b you add a b yeah it's
because of the band
shut up it's written on top of it
yeah if you were really big fans you
know how to spell this [ __ ] three ass
letter ass name sorry about that i could
tell
i'm glad we got to the root of your
trauma cause
i was like yo what is this visceral
reaction and now i understand i got to
withdraw
me i'll be honest with you people [ __ ]
up my name my whole life and it never
bothered me
because i don't think it's three letters
i don't even think it's that important
personally i think what matters what
gets to me is when you say the name and
you say it incorrectly or you don't even
try to say correctly
like even even if i meet someone from a
foreign country
you know like let's say i mean i'm gonna
go
hey ahmed hey uh iraq
yeah you know i'll say ahmed i'll try to
say it correctly
in the way it's meant to be said and so
uh i just feel like that's like the
minimum that people can do
i think with the way names are written
sometimes it's like aaron it's like
why is that name a ron you know what i'm
saying not my business that's
what a game that's how you go by that's
respect i'm gonna put respect on you now
i get that before i put respect on your
name i'm gonna spell it good first
what if i look her up on facebook and
then go to messages
this is invasive yeah she doesn't even
come up no because she's blocked
i [ __ ] hate that [ __ ] should i
unblock her so he can go yeah
[Laughter]
[Music]
empty say hi no
this producer is a busy [ __ ] you ain't
shipping this one producers you're
you're you ain't [ __ ] permanent birdman
gift
just rubbing their hands like
adsense money but i am mad at you but
you ain't [ __ ] for this one
but i ain't mad at you but you ain't
[ __ ] for this one you know what i was
thinking about early in this video
what let's see how long we can go before
this producer gets
messy because you know how the cut be
and we're not even halfway no i see him
oh no what are you gonna look at first
what am i gonna look at first i'm trying
to think of the only person that i could
think of
that would have talked any kind of [ __ ]
about me and it would be our friend
chloe
oh well it says bro you're really lucky
that you found dylan before this
generation got it [ __ ] up
ah doesn't he feel like [ __ ]
this is all her like girly friends and
they just talk about
getting dick and stuff like that
dominique say anything about you
i don't think there's anything about me
she doesn't talk to her friends about me
she doesn't like really want them to be
in our relationship at all
why because they're a bunch of bratty
girls
i mean this is why i keep my friendships
and relationships separate
well if you weren't in the group chat
before
you're not gonna be in the groups you're
gonna be in the group chat now damn
right
oh yeah okay so what are you saying now
yo i would have renamed the group
i would have renamed the group from like
seven heaven to
bratty [ __ ] get bratty [ __ ] let's
go so what what's that
what what's happening with you
co-signing on on your boyfriend calling
us body [ __ ]
huh oh i'm going to her recently
deleted photos oh it's a tick tock that
she did the other day
don't play that i was gonna be a part of
tick tock and then i said no
because it was too cringy
i like her she got good taste she said i
don't want any part of you
you're right boo boo shout out to you i
appreciate that
she's hot no i'm not it's so
embarrassing
dang dude her and her boyfriend are
ex-boyfriends with all these freaking
long aspects that's because they'd be
missing me
oh dude
and then a bunch of more audio messages
probably don't want to hear it
i appreciate do you my dude oh
[ __ ] just because the [ __ ] is out of
context i don't want to hear it
because it's just one dude's emotion
doesn't mean that she wants to
reciprocate or whatever what not
it is and he's just like you know what
i'ma exit that [ __ ]
cause it ain't got nothing to do with me
i appreciate it
i wanted to hear it that you want to get
caught
i hope so
[Laughter]
so i'm gonna text her ex and see if he
would ever able to hang out with me
no
i bet he probably would to be like yeah
let's go to a mariners game
that's the one person i did not want to
text
should i text kai shawn and ask him if
he wants to get back together with
dominique
no if you want to no blame
this wasn't my idea she missed her
chance to do this [ __ ] to me
hey no was our sex good
he's gonna show his mom and his sister
and his brother
there we go he sent it it looks
like me and dylan are having
another baby
whoa whoa i messaged
my son's dad saying that me and her
having another baby and he's just like
oh yeah
oh yeah oh yeah oh that's a good
reaction
that's a good reaction i'm not even
gonna front you like he was trying to
get the
ex the baby daddy jealous and he was
just like man get a baby
get that struggle enjoy it go ahead yeah
take it
he was this he said [ __ ] you want to
get tough
let's go now text dominique's parents
i'm pregnant
she's gonna answer it right away hey mom
i got something to tell you
what's up and you know if she calls i
want him to answer
she calling she's calling i'll call
you oh
how was that i think it was
more stressful on my end i told you i
had nothing to hide
no no the way he said it
i told you i have nothing now ten bodies
in the dumpster check around this house
this man is a killer yo but y'all
back yo the only reason you are
she wasn't even looking she was being
very kind to you you was the one being
messy
it was a producer being messy no he came
up with the idea
should i message her that was him that
was him that was him that was him you
wanna know why
why because he's auditioning
and you got the job and that's fashion
for that one of course with the head
that feeling of taking someone else's
phone
like having the access to dig through it
is it feels very invasive
it does it was fun though yeah
it was fun well congratulations
on the baby thanks is your mom texting
you right now
she says um call me
oh [ __ ] now we get to see the real
feelings about me
maybe that was the whole point of this
video he was trying to find out what his
friends
what her what are the friends and family
we're talking about because he's like
are you hiding me you ashamed of me
maybe maybe that's what it is you know
it is what it is maybe it is
would you ever um not do this thing
online but offline would you ever do
this no no no no no i don't want to see
nothing
over everything well i could there
should be no secrets in the marriage
that has nothing to do with that
no it's just and i have i have the
the i have the password of her phone she
has a password for my phone that's
pretty much it like
i don't look at it we have each other's
passwords we don't we don't we just
don't do it
you just don't go in and look for [ __ ]
you want to look for [ __ ] ask me we'll
talk but
not man we don't i wouldn't do that what
am i looking for
if you're looking for something it's
because you suspect some [ __ ]
and ask about it yeah and the worst
thing is that you st
it's stupid when you're looking for some
[ __ ] you found some [ __ ]
and you still stay why'd you look for
this [ __ ] for
you know i mean all that for nothing
shut the [ __ ] up you just like drama
no i don't i don't i don't i don't look
for [ __ ] i don't look for [ __ ]
if i don't know something i go about
this about about life
if i don't know about some [ __ ] i'm not
looking to find out
and if i'm supposed to know i will find
out
someone's gonna something's gonna fall
on my lap something or the person's
gonna tell me if i'm supposed to know
i will know someone's gonna tell them
you're intuitive enough
to like sniff out some [ __ ] not just
that if i'm supposed to know either the
person's gonna tell me or it's gonna
happen and i'm gonna know
you know what i mean if i'm not supposed
to know about people are not supposed to
know about everything
they think oh yeah you supposed to share
no
that's not true you're not supposed to
share every i don't believe that you're
supposed to share everything
every everything no there's some things
that my best friends don't know that's
something that my wife don't know
there's something i don't know about my
[Music]
wife
is
[Music]
that keeps you